let's bring in nancy cortes now with
more on how the white house is
responding the fed's move is happening
nancy separate and apart from the white
house but they're certainly interested
over there what do we know
well tony i think they're happy for the
fed to be the focus of inflation talk
for a change that's a spotlight that
they live with here every day and they
know that some of the gyrations that
we've seen on wall street recently have
to do partly with the fact that wall
street is worried that the fed didn't
act quickly enough or aggressively
enough to stem rising prices and you
know that once those worries set in it's
hard to change minds i mean in poll
after poll americans list the economy
and inflation as their number one
concerns heading into november's
elections and that's why when president
biden is out on the road these days he
doesn't sugarcoat it he doesn't say
we're turning a corner because there's a
fear here that he would look like he's
out of touch with the reality that many
americans are are facing so he blames
russia he blames the oil companies he
blames kovid and he says
that he's got a plan to address all of
this but what white house advisors
really won't say publicly is that
they've just about exhausted everything
that they can do from here to try to
bring prices down i mean they've tapped
the strategic petroleum reserve they
have tried to make ethanol restrictions
looser they've convened the major
retailers and manufacturers to try to
smooth out supply chain issues there
just isn't that much more that the
president himself can really do and so
that's the central dilemma heading into
the midterm elections how does the white
house show that it is not just focused
on this issue but it's making real
progress when their toolkit frankly is
limited michelle
nancy thank you